hallo wir sind heute in berlin und haben
besuch von virginia und ihren schülern
von der new school of northern virginia
unser thema heute sind trennbare werben
das ist etwas typisch deutschen das
heißt dass man ein verb im präsens und
präteritum trennen kann zum beispiel mit
kommen mit kommen ist der infiniti iv
ich komme mit wäre die erste person
singular wir zeigen euch jetzt einige
szenen mit trennbaren werben
jack will heute auf eine party geben
möchte mitkommen naomi kommst du mit so
partie gaben ihr gerne sechs geht jetzt
zur party kommt auch mit michael wilk
anrufen
aber er hat noch immer nicht genug
ja ich würde ihn an
michael ruf zu kann
hallo wie geht der luchs zimmer es heute
echt unheimlich klug räumt auf michael
und naomi sitzen beim essen kannst du
vielleicht abwaschen
ich muss weg
naomi ist wirklich nett wie wäscht für
michael das geschirr ab
es gibt viel müll in der küche jemand
muss den müll wegbringen bringst du den
mittelweg lok und sachsen im unterricht
überraschung
wir schreiben eine tat überhaupt zu wir
schreiben heute einen herd ich dachte
das habe ich ihm gesagt dass ich meine
aufgabe so lieben soll dazu unser video
über trennbare werden wir sind ja dann
fahre ich wieder weg mit fahren morgen
nach amerika oh morgen fliegt es schon
zurück dann eine gute reise